hello everyone welcome back to my
channel where we talk about how to have
a healthy career in tech and other
things also so we spent a lot of time at
our desks in our careers whether in tech
or not it's definitely important that we
take breaks and not sit at our desk for
all 40 hours of the workweek because
that puts a lot of strain on our bodies
but there's also a lot of tweaks and
improvements you can make to your desk
setup to improve our physical well-being
and that's through economics so Argonaut
mix is a study of combining multiple
different disciplines like physiology
anatomy engineering and psychology to
create a work environment that's more
suited to people's needs based on our
bodies and our working styles now I am
nowhere near an expert in anatomy and
physiology I took like two bio classes
in college but I wanted to back this
video up with some science so today I
have Pat Kelly from the channel corporis
which is a channel about anatomy and
physiology here today to talk about the
science behind economic s-- basically he
knows some body stuff and he dug up some
research to help us understand what's
actually good for us let's get started
so today we're gonna be talking about
all the different parts of a desk set up
chairs desks mice keyboard and monitor
height to answer the question is
ergonomic important for you and does it
actually prevent injury and stress and
we'll talk about takeaways for each of
those pieces so that you know how to set
up your work environment at home and at
the office so that it's a little bit
more comfortable and more suited for
your body one thing to note though is
that all of these things have to be done
together because you could have an
amazing chair setup but if your desk is
not good then what's the point you know
so all of these things are done in
conjunction with each other to create
the most ergonomic setup
[Music]
some of these pieces of advice have no
real evidence behind them the chairs
dude chairs have a bunch of evidence
behind them and most of the research
focuses on maintaining the spines curve
low back pain is super common and there
are a bunch of things that can cause it
but sitting for a long time and bending
forward or two of the biggest factors to
understand why though we need a quick
anatomy lesson your spine has this S
shape you've probably seen this before
it's super simple
there are bony vertebrae and squishy
disks between them the spinal cord runs
through these holes you have a bunch of
ligaments making sure your spine doesn't
move too far one way or another and a
bunch of muscles to control movement and
keep you in good posture the more you
flatten out your spine the more those
squishy insides of the disks can start
shifting backwards like squishing a
jelly doughnut a few studies have tried
to look at increasing muscle activation
around the spine through something like
an exercise ball or one of those wobbly
stools hoping that that will keep the
spine and a better curvature but what
ends up happening is that people do it
for a little bit
they slouch for a while or they just end
up getting a regular chair instead so it
completely defeats the purpose of them
researchers think that if you keep the
curve good in your lower back then your
upper back and your neck might be more
inclined to keep good posture - research
published in the journal spine in 2010
had healthy participants try out
different chair positions and examines
their posture they found that a hundred
degrees was good enough to improve the
resting spinal curve and the neck
posture but a hundred and ten degrees
was better and adding a lumbar pillow
was even better than that
a separate study in 2013 hooked little
electromagnetic sensors up to people and
gave them a little lumbar support like a
little pillow for behind their back and
they noticed the same thing not only do
the participants retain that s-curve in
their spine but they also reported
feeling more comfortable and the tip
here is to find a good chair and it
doesn't even have to be an expensive one
it just has to be one that provides
lumbar support and a tip that I like to
use to make sure that your chair is set
up for your body is to use the ninety
nine
90 rule you're looking for a 90-degree
angle in the knees a 90 degree angle in
the hips and a 90 degree angle at your
elbows so raise your chair lower your
chair whatever you gotta do to get those
90 degrees is the optimal position for
you to be sitting in a chair all right
so keyboards are the thing that I think
I pay the most attention to in a setup I
try to use a split keyboard as much as
possible because otherwise my wrists
hurt hey Pat is this actually a thing
it's totally a thing with a cool
backstory
back in the 1960s this dude named dr.
Karl Cromer wanted to find like the best
ergonomic setup for a keyboard so he
took this QWERTY keyboard split it in
half and if there was a way that he
could tweak it he tried it obviously the
wrist moves in a bunch of different ways
but the first move that seemed to make a
difference was a motion called pronation
the flat keyboard puts your wrist at 90
degrees of pronation and from his
experiments he found that people
preferred 40 to 55 degrees of pronation
he also tried something he called a k'
keyboard which was angled at 30 degrees
and had hinges in the middle these
things hung from under the desks and the
participants would touch type like they
couldn't see the keyboard other
experiments in the 80s confirmed the
same thing split keyboards with some
level of inclination were rated more
comfortable but two things can get in
the way of that
the first is typing accuracy if you
decide to buy an ergonomic keyboard and
find yourself making typing mistakes all
of a sudden you'll probably switch back
to the old one research has shown that
our bodies aren't good at picking up
those small tweaks and keyboards
immediately it takes about four months
to see the effects so you have to hang
in there for a while otherwise you might
not see the point in sticking with the
objectively healthier design the other
thing that gets in the way is aesthetics
which I'm sure you saw coming more
people will often choose the
aesthetically pleasing version of a
keyboard than the ergonomic keyboard
there is actual research that has shown
this and the practical takeaways here
are to use a split keyboard and be sure
to use it for at least four months
because it takes about that long for you
to see the benefits
of using a split keyboard and beware of
form over function I know that urban AMA
key wars are not the slickest in design
all the time but if you do use one they
can prevent some serious wrist damage so
the mouse thing isn't as clear-cut as
the past two things usually this is when
we'd start talking about repetitive
strain injury which you probably know is
RSI it's this catch-all term for overuse
injuries like carpal tunnel it's built
off this idea that if you do anything
with a joint over and over and over it's
only a matter of time before you develop
RSI and experience pain that means
there's never gonna be a single
one-size-fits-all best economic input
device but this kind of ends up being a
blessing in disguise like traditional
mice use different muscles and movement
patterns compared to track balls or
track pads or styluses on tablets
research in the International Journal of
industrial organization and neck strain
than mice but create more wrist
extension which comes with its own
problems now there's evidence from a
bunch of different industries not just
computer work that shows that switching
up your tools can help decrease RSI
symptoms
so the solution seems to be switching
input devices often and learning how to
use your other hand the trick to that is
that it just takes some time to get used
to research from 2005 found that
training with a mouse in the
non-dominant hand for 30 minutes a day
for three weeks was good enough to get
you used to alternating without it
affecting your productivity takeaway
wise the best thing is to definitely use
a mouse that's comfortable to you and if
you can change up your mouse every so
often so you're using a different one
and take breaks your wrists need a
little bit of R&R you know
assuming everything else is dialed in
with your 90 90 90 rule then there is a
little bit of wiggle room for the ideal
monitor height and monitor depth our big
goal here is maintaining neck posture
according to a study from 1998 neck
muscles were less strained from zero
degrees to 17.5 degrees and below 35
degrees it was way more uncomfortable
that's because the human eye has a
comfortable range that it can gaze up
down or side to side follow-up research
in 1999 reported that most people found
it more comfortable to gaze between
neutral and negative 26 degrees as
opposed to slightly above neutral and
slightly below neutral if you're using
an external monitor on an arm or a stand
then the height is pretty easy to adjust
right or it gets trickier is when you
only have a laptop maybe you're
constrained to your couch or kitchen
table but if you're using a laptop your
screen is way lower than seventeen and a
half degrees so you either end up
bending your neck which is not preferred
or you bring some kind of riser but even
that's troubling because now your wrists
aren't in an ergonomic position anymore
I mean it was a laptop keyboard anyway
so it already wasn't great ergonomics
but you get what I'm trying to say and
the advice that I've heard from
Organists at companies that I've worked
at all support these facts so try
setting your monitor at zero degrees
with your eyes so you're looking
straight at the top of your monitor
first see how that feels for a couple
hours or a couple days and adjust
accordingly and depending on how it
feels to you and while you're trying out
different monitor Heights
take note of your posture and take know
of whether you're straining your neck or
your shoulders or any other muscles all
of us have different bodies so there's
probably gonna be a good monitor height
that's different for all of us because
with everything in life and in tech it
depends
[Music]
so I think when a lot of people think
about ergonomics setups they often think
about standing desks now I've had mine
for a little over a year now and I feel
like they generally make me feel better
and Pat's got some interesting facts
about the relationship between desks and
ergonomics the science behind seated
desk height is pretty straightforward if
your desk sets you up to follow the 90
90 90 rule you're golden but starting
around 2012 more reports started coming
out about sitting as the new smoking
like if you sit all day you're gonna die
early so of course everybody panicked
okay we need some nuance here people who
spend most of the day seated have about
a 10 to 20 percent increased risk of
dying from heart disease that is a big
deal but people who smoke have about a
200 percent increased risk of dying from
heart disease so even that statistic
needs some more nuance attached to it
but no sitting is not smoking let's keep
that in mind
either way we do spend a lot of our
working hours seated so standing desks
became more popular and the research
followed after it now I know a couple
people who bought sit-stand desks and
never standed them they're always in the
seated position so a big question in the
research is how much of a difference do
these sit-stand desks actually make a
2018 study took 24 office workers in New
Zealand and swapped half of their seated
desks for electric adjustable height
desks basically a motorized sit-stand
desk all 24 of them track their activity
with pedometers and exercise Diaries and
that was it the research group didn't
tell them to move more they just saw
what happens and as expected the group
that switched to adjustable desks moved
around more during the day got more
steps and reported more activity in
their free time that study didn't
measure any metrics of fitness or
disease just activity which is still
important for sure other studies have
found that workers will sit less if they
receive any amount of ergonomics
training which is cool but it's really
just like an example of the Hawthorne
effect in action mat 2018 New Zealand
study was clearly for the people who
were asking will I be more active if I
buy this standing
and while it's a small sample size and
it's early days research the answer
seems to be yes
although everybody's different so
basically a desk isn't necessarily
important or prevent injury or stress
ergonomically speaking but it is better
for you health-wise because it keeps you
moving so now that we've been through
all the different parts is ergonomic
actually important yes it is and does it
actually prevent you from injury and
stress again yes but like I said at the
beginning of the video all these things
have to be done together for those
things to be true
so to summarize get a chair with lumbar
support use a split keyboard and use it
for at least four months get a mouse
that's comfortable play around with your
monitor height and standing desks to
help you move and thank you so much to
power for being in the video today to
provide the science behind it all his
channel corporis is linked in the
description box down below so be sure to
check out his stuff and if you like this
video give it a thumbs up that'll just
taught me whether you like this video
more than average which is all I got or
no and leave a comment down below
letting us know if any of these tips
were helpful to you and be sure to click
Subscribe and the notification bow that
you are notified with my videos go live
alright that's it for today I will see
you in the next one have a great day
wherever you are
bye